i'm thankful for the internet well issa
rae might be rethinking that after
sunday night when president donald trump
liked his first tweet
ever a tweet about her show insecure
shout out to the internet here's what
went down on sunday a new episode of
rey's hbo show aired and trump liked a
tweet that read
this is how i wanted tonight's episode
of insecure to end
damn molly the tweet featured this gif
of two characters from the color purple
sitting in a field of flowers playing a
hand-clapping game
confused you're not alone insecure fans
quickly took notice of the like and hit
up social media to weigh in
with comments like i think he might
break twitter with this one
and um so confused right now
then there was this twitter user who
shared a gif of a woman looking hella
perplexed
asking the question we're all thinking
trump watches
insecure thank you for that but no one
was more confused than the insecure star
and creator herself
issa rae okay well you know
after one fan brought trump's like to
her attention she replied
what the [ __ ] is this then rey's
lovebirds co-star
kumal nanjani tweeted well i found one
thing i have in common with him
we're both big fans of issa rae but rey
wasn't feeling it
responding with this gif of a woman
saying shh
don't say that that's really messed up
rey's tweets come after weeks of
amplified racial tension
in america following the death of george
floyd
a 46 year old black man who died after a
police officer pressed his knee into his
neck for more than eight minutes
his death has inspired protests against
police brutality and racial injustice
across the country
and the globe i can't breathe
trump has responded to the protests by
issuing military troops to certain
cities
celebrities like beyonce and kim
kardashian have been vocal about the
injustice of floyd's death
while taylor swift and dwayne the rock
johnson have publicly called out trump
for his response
and lack thereof to recent events
where is our leader at this time at this
time
when our country is down on its knees
begging pleading
hurt angry frustrated
in pain begging and pleading with its
arms out
just wanting to be heard